Bộ xí dẫn thì trong sau tháng đầu năm 2019, các chú đối tư nhá thâu đã có nhiều cô gắng các phục
các khó khăn về giải phóng mặt măng, mồn tung, bình lộ xí dẫn, miến lộm giá nhìn lợp,
bình lợp để trên khá ca dự án, tinh nhên là tiến độ thực hiện của một số dự án
thì con chấp, kết quả giải ngân của một số dự án chưa đắt vẫn kìp yêu cò.
Sất lệnh của lượng các con vực con lại từ nay đến cuối năm là rất lớn, trong khi thời tiết đã bắt đầu vào mũa,
bộ xây dẫn yêu cò các chú đồ tư, bán còn lý dự án để nhàng tinh độ hàn thiện các thủ tục để hợi công các dự án tư kế hoạch.
Các cuộc vũ lình qua tăng cơ kế chá, nhận dịnh các khó khăn đứng mắt, kìp thời tháng yêu,
lệ chỉ đã ông nhà thâu trên khai các dự án đáp cướng tinh độ, chỉ đã hình chương ra xuất,
tập nhật kế hoạch dài ngân các tháng còn lại của năm.
Tháng yêu đôi trình kế hoạch bộn tự các dự án sẽ nơi chợp.
Lánh đạo có đồ dị và thương xuyên có mặt tại hiện trường trụ động của hợp lòng việc với các niệf hơn,
để tháo gước khó khăn vướng mắt, lạc biệt là tục tăng dài phó mắt bằng tự lượng xây dẫn.
Tập trung thực hiện các dài pháp viện phát liên hoạch sáng tạo kìp thời hiệu quà,
quyết liệt để đảy ngàng tính độ thí cầu và giải ngân vốn đầu tư cầu đã phân bộ.
Vết định ngàng tính độ ở phía cắn với bảo đàn trực lượng công trình không để sử dát yêu cầu,
tất hoa tọn phí bị phạm quyết định pháp lần.